can you tell us the difference between a
$10,000 documentary versus a hundred
thousand five hundred thousand two
million what do you get at each price
point well at ten thousand dollars
you're not going to get a lot you're not
you you can make a documentary for ten
thousand dollars but you'll have to do
either a lot of the crew positions
yourself or have people that will you
know volunteer their time to do it for
you so you're gonna have to ask for a
lot of freebies but you can do a
documentary for ten thousand you can buy
that camera that we're shooting on today
for you know three thousand with the
lens there abouts and you're gonna be
able to buy your zoom recorder and
you're gonna be able to buy you know a
few lights and what have you and so you
can get in business for probably under
under five and then if you're not
traveling and you're just shooting you
know in your area then it's you can and
it's your own gear you can shoot as many
days as you want if you're not hiring
crews so you can do it on ten thousand
dollars but at each price point if you
go next go up to the hundred thousand
dollar documentary now you're going to
be able to pay people what their normal
industry rate is you know on the ten
thousand dollar documentary you're not
going to bring out a makeup person but
for between six and eight hundred
dollars a day you just can't do that you
can't buy a full HD Crew for thirty five
hundred dollars a day rental with Sam so
but a hundred thousand dollars you're
gonna get the full HD crew at their
normal rate about thirty five hundred
west with sound that's with lights
that's with if you need a lighting
director and his grip
you know cart that's seven hundred bucks
or two one thousand dollars you're gonna
be able to afford that you're gonna be
able to afford a gaffer if you need it
just to make everything look better
you're gonna be able to afford now maybe
needle drop music - royalty free from a
music library now you can bring a
composer in not at the highest end but
for fifteen or seventeen thousand
dollars maybe one hundred thousand I
wouldn't do that
two hundred fifty I would bring in that
that level of composer but so you're
just gonna be able to travel a bit if
you have interviews across the country
you need for your show you still need to
know where to economise in other words
do you need a hundred thousand dollars
you're not flying your DP you know
direct your photography to new york you
you're getting a local crew in some
cases you might
have to even hire a local stringer
director if it's not a huge interview to
do the interview for you sometimes
you've directed over Skype or what have
you if you want to be you know if you
want to be sure I've done that many
times so for a hundred thousand dollars
you'll get to travel you get more crew
days more shoot days you'll be able to
buy some clips some archival footage you
go up next to go up to five hundred
thousand it's more of the same more prep
more research more shoot days more
travel everybody gets paid industry
standards for what they're doing better
music better graphics better color
grading so and on up to million dollars
you can you can now maybe if you had a
pop song you wanted to buy very
expensive to license music but you'll
have a better Original Score you might
even buy some some songs again better
more travel more prep archival footage
I've spent on some films over $100,000
on clips and Stills and that's what
you're going to get either at a five
hundred or two million dollar price
point you're going to be able to go to
Getty and say I need you know 188 Stills
and they'll make a deal with you I need
you know forty six minutes of archival
footage of this event you know I did a
movie call nine days that changed the
world where pope john paul ii visits
poland in 1979 and sparks this movement
that becomes the Solidarity movement
which eventually takes down communism in
Poland I needed a lot of archival
footage we found some that the Polish
Bishops Council had shot that was
unearthed in a in a room and poet that
Polish television that had been sitting
in Cannes for thirty years but I still
had to buy other stills and clips so
that adds up and you know you're gonna
have so on a two million price point you
can have 100 to 150 thousand dollar clip
budget or more so those are the various
things it's it really comes down to prep
and shoot days and how you pay your crew
and travel and music and graphics and
everything that makes your and that
makes your film more and more polished
so it's possible to be a one-man band
but it's not going to get you very far
in terms of legitimizing the document
because just the production value no no
I wouldn't say that at all I would say
you could make that's the great thing
about these cameras and and say if you
buy an HD LSR and you buy a subscription
to Adobe the cloud now for $49 a month
now you have access to their entire
editing suite their After Effects
Photoshop you know Premiere Pro so you
can and if you teach yourself those
skills you can do all that and if you
teach yourself out around the camera you
can do that now the thing that the cuffs
nothing is finding the great story it's
always about finding the great story you
know you can have what if your neighbor
is this old-time movie actress that has
a great story to tell and he's just
sitting in her house waiting for you to
come over there and film her that cost
you nothing so the story cost you know
if you have access and access is another
thing we could talk about that's the
whole that's the critical nature along
with the story structure and knowing how
to tell a story it's access to your
subject in that case on the $10,000
price point if you have a story with
heart and soul that you shot you could
have made that for five hundred dollars
conceivably if you had your camera and
you never didn't buy anything and you
actually learned all these skills and
did it yourself might take you a year or
two to do but you could that could be
just as good as any documentary that
cost a million dollars it's what's the
story what's the human story should look
at Sugarman now that was that's four
hundred thousand dollars but he was
actually he had it he had the nub of
that movie for about 80 I guess before
he went and he met with the producer one
of the producers of bird on man and wire
I think in London and he showed him just
a little bit and the guy said this is
magnificent we have to he was able to
complete the funding but the core of
that film was the story and that was
just calling people up they weren't
charging you I don't believe in that
case in most cases not they're not
charging you to tell them that for you
to tell their story that you found their
story that's so that's gold that's the
goal that's priceless and it doesn't
matter if you're using a $3,000 camera
or in an air flex al Alexa so you know
it's always about the story and the
storytelling skill really
you